anchor david asman in focus now you said
that potentially this could come yeah
well
remember we have i mean this let's let's
not uh bury the lead here this is a good
jobs number very good job i said that
and normally 100 000 more than what was
expected uh the problem is that
americans are running out of savings
americans built up this huge pile of
savings during the pandemic because of
the lockdowns where they couldn't go out
and spend money on vacations and stuff
2.7 trillion dollars of savings was
developed over the pandemic uh that that
created a tremendous buffer for them
coming coming out of the pandemic of
course they've been spending a lot in
the past six months since or years since
we got out of the lockdowns but
inflation has kicked up at the same time
and what's happening now is that
americans are actually dipping into
their savings because of inflation so
they're running out of their savings
what do you do when you're at home and
you run out of savings you go back to
work a lot of people who had been
sitting on the fence are now seeing
these 11 million jobs cherry-picking the
really good ones and there are a lot of
good ones out there and going getting
jobs that's the news and potentially
making a little bit more money as
the employers have been desperate to get
people to come back to work so those
those bonuses and things are we going to
start to see some of that go away though
uh you're
you will because of the fact that the
businesses themselves are suffering from
inflation i mean particularly if you
think of restaurant businesses and those
that are most vulnerable to the
inflationary pressures uh for the cost
of of gas the cost of fuel that they use
in these businesses uh the fact that
that they're they're having they're
still having difficulty in in getting
workers a lot of them are going out of
business right now and that's why there
are recessionary concerns that's why we
had a 1.6 percent drop in the gdp in the
first quarter and the atlanta fed for
one is suggesting we'll have another
drop in the second quarter two quarters
back to back of negative growth
indicates a recession
so we might be in a recession and that
means that a lot of those 11 million job
openings will dry up i'm going to ask my
team uh to pop up labor secretary marty
walsh she was pressed on part of biden's
plan to spend more money to bring down
the cost of things so he's going to hit
inflation with more cash watch this
i don't i wouldn't make an elected
official decision based on what's going
to add to inflation if you're going to
help the american worker and help the
american family and that's what the
president quite honestly is doing
i thought that was part of how we got
here yeah well and it's not just that
not just spending more cash which is
what causes inflation as you say it's
also the fact that they're thinking of
raising taxes particularly on small
businesses right now there was a
washington post piece today uh
suggesting that joe manchin who was
against the bbb bill he essentially
killed the build back better bill of
that that huge five trillion dollar
spending program but he's now working
with senator schumer uh and all you need
are the all 50 democrats to vote for
something and they can get it because of
reconciliation so what could it look
like well what what it can look like we
go back to coming out of the recession
in 2009 just when we were coming out of
the recession 2009 2010 president then
president obama raised taxes and raised
regulations and we ended up with the
slowest recovery in our history in our
our modern history anyway in the 20th
century so so we could end up with
serious problems if in fact they do
exactly the wrong thing at the wrong
time this this jobs number is good it's
good because we have that buffer of job
openings 11 million job openings but if
those begin to close up because of of a
recession or something close to a
recession uh then we're really going to
be out of luck and you don't want to
kill small businesses even more by
raising their taxes wow and and we used
to talk about joe manchin in a different
way as he stood between the president
spending more money with with bill back
better
and now
we find out again not that we doubted
that he was a democrat but that he could
work with chuck schumer it's still it's
still not a sure thing the washington
post may not have it entirely correct
we'll wait and see but the pressure is
on mansion you don't want that kind of
recovery that false recovery like we had
in 2009 10 11. and axios analysis says
that the jobs numbers carry risk in both
directions but the so-called goldilocks
scenario is the hope of both financial
markets and the white house axios
explains it as an economy still
expanding with workers able to find jobs
readily without further tightening of
the labor market to goad the fed into
raising rates too far too fast break
that down well the axios has it wrong
the economy is not expanding it's
contracting we had a 1.6 contraction in
the first quarter so with the economy
that is the problem the economy is not
expanding right now it's contracting we
won't get this the final numbers of the
second quarter until the end of this
month uh but if in fact we're we're
online to what the atlanta fed says
we're going to have two contractions two
quarters back to back of the contracting
economy and that's a recession david
this is not our first rodeo why do we
keep riding the ponies we got to get
back up on the big horses that's a great
question and we know what causes
inflation we know it's it's big
government spending money they don't
have and the fed prints phony money in
order to pay those expenses it's
politics but but more than that we we
have an election coming up uh and and a
lot of people uh particularly in the
democratic side but some republicans are
doing it too think the easiest way to
get elected is by spending not their
money but taxpayer money so it is
politics yeah it is hey it's will kane
click here to subscribe to the fox news
channel on youtube it's the best way to
get our latest interviews and highlights
and click to subscribe to the will kane
podcast for full episodes right now